Helen Walters: Hello everyone.
Happy 2024 wherever you are.
It is January 8, and I don't know
about you, but here at TED,
we are looking forward to the year ahead
with a sense of nervous anticipation.
As we all know, there is a lot going on,
from war on multiple fronts
to upcoming elections
that some say will determine no less
than the future of democracy.
This is big, this is concerning.
It's often slightly confounding.
So given all that, we want to move
forward with eyes wide open,
and who better to help us understand
exactly what to pay attention to this year
than president of Eurasia Group
and GZERO media, Ian Bremmer.
Ian, hi,
Ian Bremmer: Helen, good to be with you.
HW: So, Ian, you've just published
your annual list of Top Risks for 2024,
and I want to dive right in.
The very first one that you describe is
called "the United States versus itself."
So tell us.
IB: Helen, the United States today
has an incredibly strong
economy and military.
Its political system is in crisis.
The US is the only advanced
industrial democracy
that cannot ensure a free
and fair transition of power
that is seen as legitimate
by a majority of its population.
That is what we are looking at in 2024,
and it's happening against a context
of a geopolitical environment
that is very deeply unstable,
with a major war between
Russia and Ukraine,
which is nowhere close to ending,
with a major war between Israel and Hamas,
which is nowhere close to ending.
And so both allies of the United States
are deeply concerned about this,
and adversaries are looking
to take advantage.
Now for 2024,
we won't have a new president
if there is a new president,
that's next year.
So why is it so risky now?
Well, it's so risky now
because the country is so divided
and because Trump is likely
to get the nomination
overwhelmingly likely, and when he does,
his policy pronouncements
will drive the GOP.
And they are not right now, as of today.
So in other words, overnight,
he will gain the loyalty,
regain the loyalty of the overwhelming
majority of Republican leaders
in state legislatures,
in the House, in the Senate,
and of Republican-leaning
and right-leaning media outlets
and, of course, the ability to raise money
and deploy that money for the election.
And that means
that his policy orientations,
as he expresses them,
whether it's cutting off Zelensky
and the Ukrainians
or showing the Iranians what's what,
and that's why they wouldn't
have gone to war
against Israel and the US
if he had been president,
unlike Biden.
Or in terms of the border,
vis a vis the Mexicans,
any other issues,
those are suddenly going to be drivers
of one half of the US political system.
So it's a deeply concerning
political environment,
and one that the United States is not
in a position to respond to effectively.
HW: So, Ian, you've written
that there is an unlikely
but plausible possibility
that the US won't actually even be able
to hold a free and fair election
on November 5.
We're going to talk more
about the impact of artificial
intelligence in a little bit,
but the reality is that we have seen
the impact of misinformation
on elections before.
But in the ensuing time,
things have gotten much [worse],
much quicker.
So what should we be watching for there,
and how do you think that is going
to play out in November in the US?
IB: Well, the United States,
as the most powerful country in the world
and as a political democracy,
which is in crisis,
the most vulnerable part
of the United States
is its political system
and is specifically its 2024 election.
That is the Achilles heel
for the United States.
When I speak with the intelligence
leaders in the United States,
they say that is what
they are most concerned about.
It's the vulnerability of the US election.
It's not the Russians attacking
the Americans militarily,
it's not a big fight with the Chinese,
it's not Iran,
it's the vulnerability
of the US elections.
And that vulnerability
is a comparatively complex
and soft target from a homeland
security perspective.
Especially because Americans don't live
in the same information environment.
You know, we talk about climate
change around the world,
and everyone agrees
that there's 1.2 degrees of warming.
Everyone agrees there's 442 parts
per million of carbon in the atmosphere.
When you talk about the US
political system,
everyone does not agree
that Trump tried illegally
to overturn an election.
I mean, in a normal democracy,
in a well-functioning democracy,
that would obviously be
the top issue of debate
in the election.
Is the fact that you're thinking
about re-electing someone
that is, you know, not interested
in a democratic election.
That is not what is happening
presently in the United States.
Not at all.
And that is not Trump's fault.
Trump is a symptom, a very serious symptom
of the fact that US institutions
have been delegitimized over decades.
And it's getting worse.
And he's a very happy
beneficiary of that reality.
So, yes, I do worry
that American political institutions,
and specifically, the electoral procedures
are vulnerable to that,
especially because the stakes
are so much higher this time around.
The stakes are higher
for Biden and his team
because they believe
that they may face an end
to an effective multi-party
transfer of power over time
if Trump wins.
A lot of them individually believe
that they would face legal jeopardy
from a politicized Department
of Justice or FBI or IRS
if Trump is in power.
They absolutely say that privately.
And of course, Trump believes, to himself,
much more dangerous
than the end of democracy,
Trump believes that he would face jail,
he and maybe even
members of his family,
if he were to lose the election.
So the stakes are very high indeed
in the United States.
They're very high indeed
outside the United States.
HW: I think the reality that you're
describing is that whoever wins,
whoever the nominees are, Biden, Trump,
whoever wins,
things aren't necessarily
going to get better, right?
IB: Yeah, I guess I'm trying to say
that neither Biden nor Trump
have the capacity and the willingness
to try to fix this.
I don't believe that Trump is interested,
never mind having the capacity.
I believe that he benefits.
He believes he benefits from referring
to his adversaries politically as enemies,
as enemies of the people.
And as painting them
as an existential threat
to the Republic of the United States.
You know, they're Marxists,
they're communists,
it's a new McCarthyism, if you will.
And that Biden
certainly has the willingness
to try to fix this yawning divide
in the United States.
But four years of being president
hasn't fixed it, right?
I mean, there was a belief
among many Biden supporters
that if you elected this guy,
that the United States was going
to be able to become more normal,
and Biden has had
a lot of legislative successes,
his infrastructure package
that was bipartisan,
that Trump was unable to pass,
the Inflation Reduction Act, misnamed,
but nonetheless significant
amounts of money
for investment into red
and blue-state jobs,
more red-state than blue-state jobs,
other policies as well.
And yet the divisions
in the United States,
the dysfunction
of the US political system,
the perceived illegitimacy of major
US political institutions and the media,
has only increased
under four years of Biden.
So you have this very unusual environment
where the most powerful
leaders in the country
are not able to fix the problem.
And it's not like there's any diplomacy
that's happening between them.
I mean, the interesting thing
about our view of the Top Risks of 2024
is that you have these three
major conflicts,
three major wars that are essentially
happening in the world.
You've got, you know, Russia-Ukraine,
which is now entering its third year,
You've got Israel-Hamas,
which is in its third month.
And then you've got the US versus itself,
which is kicking off right now.
And in all three of those cases,
there's no plausible environment
in the coming year
where diplomacy is going
to reduce those tensions,
is going to end or even
contain that conflict.
And in all three of those wars,
the leaders do not share
the same information space.
They don't even agree
on the same basic set of facts.
And that is an unprecedentedly
dangerous geopolitical environment
in your and my lifetimes, Helen.
HW: So let's talk about these
international conflicts.
So you mentioned three of them,
one, the United States versus itself.
Let's turn to the Middle East.
Let's talk about what's going on
with Israel-Hamas.
Do you feel like this is going
to spiral into a broader conflict?
IB: I do, I do.
I'm not confident
exactly what the avenue
of that escalation is likely to be,
but I'm very confident there are so many
avenues that that escalation can occur.
And it's not within the capacity
of the United States
or other major countries around the world
or in the region to contain it.
And let's talk about a few.
One, of course, is Hezbollah
and the northern border
between Israel and Lebanon.
And that fighting,
as we speak, is escalating.
The missiles from Hezbollah into Israel,
the Israeli assassination
of a Hamas political leader in Beirut,
the willingness of the Israeli defense
forces to go against Hezbollah targets,
That is escalating.
And it's not just
Prime Minister Netanyahu,
though he's very relevant,
because if the war is over,
he's going to be out of power,
and he could very well face jail,
but it's also the entire
Israeli war cabinet
that believes that they
cannot end this war
and allow actors in the region
that believe that Israel
has no right to exist,
they can't allow them
to maintain power the way they did
in the status quo ante before October 7.
And that's not just "destroying" Hamas,
however that is defined to be,
but also,
Hezbollah operating
right on the border
in contravention of the UN
Security Council resolution.
So they intend to back
Hezbollah off of that,
to degrade their capacity
to attack Israel to a degree.
There's also a willingness
of the Israelis to see that happen
with the Houthis in Yemen,
with Iraqi and Syrian radical Shia proxies
of the Iranian government.
The United States is now
increasingly actively fighting
all of those actors in Yemen,
in Iraq and in Syria,
and increasingly looks like
it might be willing to target Houthis
in their Yemeni bases themselves.
And that's even before we talk
about the radicalization
of millions of Palestinians
and their fellow Arab
and Muslim supporters
all over the world
on the back of the suffering
that they are experiencing,
principally, but not only, in Gaza.
Gaza is not livable right now
for two-plus million Palestinians,
but they have nowhere to go.
Those pressures are going to grow.
The Israeli government
will be calling for their removal,
into other territories like the Sinai,
which will be seen to be ethnic cleansing
by almost everyone else,
including the Biden administration
in the United States.
That radicalization will lead
to lone-wolf violence
and terrorist attacks,
will lead to coordinated
terrorist attacks,
not just in the region,
but also in Europe,
also in the United States.
So when you add all of that up,
what you see is that it is much easier
to understand how this conflict
will escalate substantially over 2024
than threading a needle to see
how you might be able to contain it,
largely to Israel versus Hamas
in this tiny strip of land
that two-plus million Palestinians
are trying to live on, in Gaza.
That is where we are right now
in the Middle East.
And this is deeply concerning
for the United States,
because the US, in their support
of this Israeli war,
is more isolated on the global stage
than the Russians were,
even when they invaded Ukraine
two years ago.
And this also is a serious problem,
not just for US projection
of power around the world,
especially with the global South,
but also domestically
among Biden's Democratic supporters,
a majority of whom are more inclined
to support the Palestinian cause
than the Israeli cause.
And so this is, as the conflict escalates,
a proximate danger
to Biden's re-election efforts,
which he is keenly aware of
but has very little he can do about it.
HW: Right, the interconnections
and the tangled web
becomes ever more tangled
as more actors get involved.
This is a really like, a stupid,
deliberately stupid question.
But do you feel like any hopes
for a two-state solution are vapor?
IB: They're not vapor,
but they ain't close.
I mean, I don't see,
in the foreseeable future, "security,"
if I can use that term,
will be provided by Israel
and not by anybody else.
And you know, what that means
in the context of Gaza is hard to define.
It's mostly about security
for the Israelis.
It's not about security
for the Palestinians, but long-term,
you can't have a two-state solution
unless you have effective governance
that is seen as legitimate by Palestinians
living in Gaza and the West Bank,
and the ability to defend themselves.
The Israelis have made it very clear,
they have a right to defend themselves.
And that has failed,
in part because the Israeli government
was asleep at the switch
before October 7.
Israeli intelligence, defense forces
and, most importantly,
their prime minister and government,
who had other priorities.
And also because they are surrounded
by a number of organizations
that do not recognize their right
to exist in the territory of Israel.
So, absolutely,
the Israelis have a right to ensure
the security of their people.
But the Palestinians have that right, too.
The difference is that the Israelis
not only have the right,
they also have the capacity.
They've got Iron Dome,
provided in large part
by the United States,
financed as well.
They've got an incredible
asymmetrical military advantage,
not only over the Palestinians,
but over everyone in the region.
They only need to apply it effectively.
And apply it effectively without killing
tens of thousands of civilians, right?
While the Palestinians have
the right to self-defense,
as is continually enshrined in votes
at the General Assembly
by the vast majority of countries
from all over the world,
including American allies,
they just don't have the ability.
And you can't talk
about a two-state solution
until you can get the Palestinians
the ability to govern themselves
and defend themselves.
And we are very, very, very
far away from that.
And since we're just talking
about 2024 today,
there is no two-state solution
in the cards for 2024.
As we think about a longer-
term environment,
there will be no peace in the region
until you find a plausible solution
that is sustainable,
where Palestinians feel
like they can raise their children
with security and economic opportunity.
We would all want only that for our kids,
and they presently do not have that.
They don't have anything
remotely close to that.
HW: Alright, so one of the other risks
that you determine in the report
is one of "partitioned Ukraine,"
which is not a phrase that Ukrainians
are going to be excited about,
but it's one that you actually think
is going to become a reality in 2024.
So tell us what's going on here.
IB: Yeah, I want to be clear
that writing about partitioned Ukraine
is not a personal preference.
It is not something
I think we should want.
that the Ukrainians will recognize.
It is not something Ukrainian friends
and allies will recognize.
But, Helen, you and I know
that there are many things in the world
that we want that are not so.
And it turns out that we live with them
for a very long time.
I mean, the North Koreans,
we do not accept
that they have nuclear weapons.
They don't really care if we accept it.
They have nuclear weapons.
Denuclearization is not happening, right?
So that's a reality.
Ukraine is presently partitioned.
And their ability,
as much as the Americans, in principle,
would like them to be able
to take their land back,
and they have every right
to be able to do so,
the invasions in 2014
and then in 2022, right,
were illegal.
The Ukrainians did nothing,
to, you know, force them.
And yet they can't take their land back.
The American ability
and willingness to continue to lead
in providing military support
that would allow the Ukrainians
to get the 18 percent of their land
that is presently occupied by the Russians
and has been for a year now,
that just does not exist in 2024.
And in fact, the bigger danger
is that the trajectory of this war
is at a turning point.
And that not only will the Ukrainians
not be able to get their land back,
but that they might not have
the people to continue to fight
to keep the land they presently have.
And that their ability
to get ongoing support,
especially from the Americans,
when this is becoming
a political divide in the US,
far away,
Israel-Palestine -- higher priority,
US elections -- higher priority.
Trump, if he's elected, at least 50-50,
I'd put it a little higher
than that, frankly,
though, I don't have a lot
of confidence around it,
would end support
to Zelensky, no question.
This is going to make the Ukrainians
feel incredibly vulnerable
and increasingly desperate.
That is what we're looking at in 2024.
And of course, that not only threatens
Ukraine's territorial integrity ongoing,
and Zelensky as a leader,
but it also threatens the integrity
of the transatlantic alliance,
which had been getting stronger
over the last couple of years
post Russian invasion,
and threatens the integrity of NATO
as an ongoing alliance,
the most important military alliance
on the planet today
So there's a lot going on here.
And presently, the outcomes
don't look great.
HW: So you have an interesting
phrase in the report
that stated "Ukraine is at risk of losing,
Russia has no way to win."
So what does that stalemate
actually look like in practical terms?
IB: So Ukraine is at risk of losing.
Ukraine doesn't have to lose.
There are still outcomes
where the Ukrainians can win,
even though they will be
de facto partitioned.
Now, that may not sound easy,
and it's not.
But let me throw you out a scenario
where the Americans are able to provide
another 20, 30 billion dollars this year,
the Europeans continue to provide
significant economic support,
harder with the Hungarians opposing,
harder with the Germans
and their emergency budget situation,
but it can happen.
And some of that could be taken,
some of the frozen assets,
legally problematic, of Russia
and applying them
to Ukrainian reconstruction.
On top of that, you fast-track
EU integration and reform in Ukraine,
and you fast-track NATO membership,
which cannot happen tomorrow.
But it could happen within, you know,
say, you get all the countries together,
the NATO allies, and say,
within two, three years
you're going to provide
them NATO membership.
It will not include territory
that the Russians are occupying
because you're not going to go
to war directly with the Russians,
but it will mean that these countries
will defend Ukraine
in the remaining territory.
That is a narrow path.
But if it happens,
you will have 80 percent
of Ukrainian territory
that has a far better trajectory
for their people
than Ukraine ever could have imagined
had the Russians not invaded.
None of that, none of that will make good
the eight million people
who have been displaced,
the tens of thousands that have had
war crimes committed against them,
the children that have been abducted
and forced into Russia
and on and on and on.
I am not minimizing the crimes
that have been committed
that they will remember
for generations in Ukraine.
But I'm saying that Ukraine
still has a path to win,
given what their country
looked like and was facing
before 2022
or before 2014.
But irrespective of whether Ukraine
can accomplish that or will lose,
the Russians will not win.
And what I mean by that
is Russia absolutely will be able
to maintain control
of a strip of Ukrainian territory.
Bombed out, right?
And not productive,
and years, if not decades,
to turn that land around economically.
But Russia will now be facing
the rest of Ukraine
with a visceral hatred for all things
Russia for generations.
I mean, think about, you know,
sort of the Turkish genocide
against the Armenians
and for how long that drove
this historic enmity.
That's what we're talking about.
This is like, you know,
Hutu-Tutsi stuff, right,
in Rwanda and Burundi,
That's what you're talking about.
And you have an expanded NATO,
including Finland,
far more territory for the Russians
to have to defend,
which ostensibly was the reason
that the Russians went to war
against Ukraine,
is because they didn't want
NATO to be encroaching.
Well they're encroaching a lot more now.
Hundreds of billions of dollars
of Russian assets
that they will not have access to.
Trade of Russia with the Europeans,
with the United States -- no more, right?
I mean, the Germans,
much more quickly moving
to a post-carbon energy transition
with no more Russian gas,
because they cut the Russians off,
at enormous cost to Germany,
but greater cost long-term
to the Russians.
Not to mention the million-plus
Russian civilians
who have fled: young men capable, smart,
that got out of dodge to anywhere,
to the Emirates, to Georgia,
to anywhere that would accept them
so they wouldn't have to fight.
And those are people that you could have
used productively in the Russian economy.
So, I mean, in this environment,
where Russia's only true friends,
providing military support for them,
are Belarus, North Korea, Iran, right,
I mean, this is -- with friends
like those, right?
I mean, there's no way.
I understand that if you're a tanky,
as they call it,
or if you're supported by the Kremlin
and you're posting dutifully on Twitter/X
that you will oppose
everything I just said
because it's your job.
But I mean, for those of us
that take a blue sky approach,
which is that we look at it
and we kind of understand the science,
it's impossible to say the Russians
are winning here.
And that's a great cost
to the rest of the world,
to the rest of the world.
This was the worst
misjudgment, in my view,
of any major leader on the global
stage since the Wall came down,
was Putin's decision to invade
Ukraine in 2022.
And not only was it a horrible decision,
it was a horrible decision
that was facilitated by the Americans
and the Europeans,
who, after the 2014 invasion,
much smaller, didn't do anything.
In fact, they kept doing business
with Russia as usual.
They hosted the World Cup,
president said, "OK, we'll still go over."
I mean, there were lots of signs
that Putin got that said,
"These guys don't care.
So we're going to get away with this."
And unfortunately,
they were really, really wrong.
HW: All right, let's change
subject a little bit.
We mentioned artificial
intelligence earlier.
And obviously, 2023 was the year
in which generative AI went mainstream.
So it's exciting, and it's mind-blowing.
And it's also led to something of a schism
between some people who are super excited
about its creative potential
and then others who can't believe
that we're barreling
towards existential end of humanity
with such nonchalance.
So you just have to see
the management drama at OpenAI
that happened at the end of 2023
to understand some of the stakes here.
But this isn't just about Silicon Valley,
and I think it's important
that we all recognize
that this is actually
going to affect all of us.
So what do you think
we should be focused on
when it comes to AI,
and what are we going to see in 2024?
IB: I am both of those things.
I'm an enormous enthusiast about AI.
I think it's a transformative technology
for everyone that has access to it,
and we're just seeing
the beginnings of that.
One of the reasons I'm most excited
about AI is because it is transformative
not just in displacing existing
powerful people and institutions.
So climate change, people get very
excited about the transition.
But to do that transition,
you've got to end oil.
And so fossil fuel players
and those that are attached to them,
infrastructure, transport
and the rest, have a lot to lose.
AI, like, even if you're a coal miner,
you can and will use AI to be
much more effective at mining coal.
You know, AI, you're like
a traditional airline company.
You can use AI to reduce, you know,
energy intensity in the contrails.
You're going to do that tomorrow, right?
So it's astonishing how much uplift
we will get from productivity
and efficiency in every sector,
from all sorts of corporations
and from individual workers,
by using these tools,
by deploying these tools.
So I'm very excited about how much
we will get out of AI
to unlock human potential
broader and faster.
But I don't spend much time
talking about that, usually,
because you've got a lot
of people and companies
that are worth trillions
of dollars collectively
that are spending
all of their time and effort
doing that as fast as humanly possible.
And they have to, because if they don't,
they've got very smart and well bankrolled
people breathing down their neck
that would be very happy
to displace them, right?
That's the principle AI displacement
we're going to see
in the next 24 months,
will be of AI players
that get taken out by other AI players
because it's so cutthroat and fast.
But there aren't people
that are spending their time thinking
about what are the challenges
for the common good.
What are the negative externalities
that come from AI?
I mean, so you think
about the last industrialization
and Americans in particular, my country,
we are so great at the private market
when it comes to profits.
We're capitalists when
it comes to the markets,
because when we do well
and money is to be made,
we make sure that we deploy that
and the shareholders get it,
and we're focused.
But when there are losses,
we are the world's best socialists.
It's not us.
It's like, somebody else.
Everyone's got to pay for it.
We're not responsible.
Preferably the kids.
And maybe not now, but maybe later.
And we've seen that with climate change.
Very happy to make all the money
from industrialization.
But I mean the costs
of emitting more carbon?
Not it, not our problem.
Well, that's a long, global, slow
process over generations.
AI is a very fast, transformative
process over like, five to 10 years.
And the negative externalities are going
to happen essentially simultaneously
with all of the positive
productivity and efficiency gains.
And we need a governance environment
where those are accounted for
and paid for.
And in the near-term,
I am not talking
about the robots taking over,
existential risk of artificial
general intelligence.
I'm talking about AI
being used by bad actors
or indifferent actors
with challenging business models
in ways that will undermine
stable society.
I'm talking about,
in particular, disinformation
and how it can be deployed
to undermine democracy.
And I'm also talking
about the disruptive nature
of proliferated AI tools
in the hands of large
numbers of governments
and institutions and individuals
that are bad actors or tinkerers
that want to destroy things
or thinking about it.
I mean, whether they're using
AI for malware
or they're using AI to build viruses
or lethal autonomous weapons.
And I think that that is really becoming
a risk only for the first time
in the coming year.
In elections, like the US election,
especially as the next generation
of AI comes out
and this is moving three times
faster than Moore's Law.
So every six months you're getting
a doubling capacity, which is, you know,
not an environment that traditional
governments are able to respond to.
It's too fast, it's too powerful.
And you're also getting those tools
in the hands of hundreds of millions
of people in very, very short order.
So there is governance,
it is coming fast, it is urgent.
But in 2024, the speed of the technology
is much, much faster
than the speed of the governance.
And that gap will create crises.
HW: I mean, we've seen,
from the whole of the OpenAI kerfuffle
that happened at the end of the year,
you really see these tensions
kind of playing out in real time.
And there are people
within large corporations
who are trying to do
the right thing internally,
but then, of course, competition
is actually driving them
to move faster and faster
so that they don't get left behind.
Given the fact that, as you say,
there are these bad actors
outside of these organizations
who are also trying to do their thing
with the open-source technologies
that are being released, etc.
What actual governance is possible
in that environment?
IB: There's a lot of governance
that is possible in that environment,
but it's not clear how quickly
we can get there.
So I mean, the EU has their AI Act,
which is quite comprehensive
in the way it thinks about regulation
and transparency of foundational models
and testing of those models of AI.
And in making sure it's not
just being done internally.
And in watermarking
and trying to make sure
that people are aware of what kind
of images they're seeing
and audio, and what's being driven by AI
and what is not.
And also the deployment of AI models
and what kind of data they have access to,
all of those things.
And the US has an executive order,
which is not as powerful as legislation,
which is not coming anytime soon,
given the divided nature
of the US government.
But still, you know,
represents a step change
in how you think about regulating
these technologies.
But these processes
are happening much more slowly
than the tech is rolling out.
So I think what governance will get you
is it will identify the actors
that are critical,
both inside governments
and in the private sector.
It will have them talking
about the issues that really matter,
and better set up so that when
a crisis occurs, and it will,
that they will be able to identify
and respond to it collectively
and much more quickly than they would
absent that governance structure.
So in this regard,
AI is a little bit more
like the financial sector,
where we all know that we need
a functioning financial sector.
And that's true whether
we're capitalists like in the US
or we're state capitalists, like in China,
you got a free, you know,
sort of, convertible currency
or you've got a closed market.
Doesn't matter.
We all know we need a financial market.
But we also know that in a global
financial market,
that individual actors
can cause systemic crises.
And so we need a stability board,
that when there is a crisis,
everyone identifies it
and responds immediately
so that we don't have a global meltdown,
don't face a depression.
That's what governance is going to need
to be able to do on the AI front.
And the thing is about AI,
we're not just talking about,
oh, someone's making a run on the market
and this company is going to go bankrupt.
The risks that potentially come
from AI and misuse of AI
are in many, many different types
of technologies and applications.
So you're going to have to,
you're going to have to essentially
build the ship as you're steering it,
because the dangers
are going to change very quickly.
HW: No problem, we'll do that just fine.
So there is another part
to the tech challenge of 2024
that is actually around
the building of tech.
And that's about the minerals
and the materials
that actually go into building tech.
So your hunch within this report
is that governments
are going to turn protectionist,
they're going to disrupt
the flow of minerals
that are needed to build
all of this technology.
So what should we be paying
attention to here,
and how much of a risk do you think
that this is for the future?
IB: Well, one is, it's related
to the high-tech front,
which is that the biggest fight
between the US and China,
which thankfully has a more stable
and more managed relationship in 2024
than they did coming into 2023.
One of the big areas of tension
is on the high-tech side.
And the Chinese are trying to develop AI,
the Americans are trying to develop AI,
but the US, with their allies,
are now taking semiconductor capabilities
and trying to ensure that they
are being built in trusted countries,
and they're putting export controls
on semiconductors,
cloud computing, related infrastructure.
And so the Chinese don't have access
to the most valuable stuff.
Now, China doesn't build its own
high-tech semiconductors.
And they are, you know,
by most accounts, about 10 years behind.
And they don't have a really
good way to counter that,
aside from investing as much as they can
inside their own country to rebuild it.
So some of what they're trying to do
is see if there's a way
to engage with the Americans
that might loosen some
of those export controls.
And that's one of the reasons,
the principal reason, actually,
why China expressed a willingness
to join a new Track 1.5 dialogue
with the Americans
on artificial intelligence.
But, the Chinese response has been,
well, you guys are dominant
in semiconductors,
but we're dominant in critical minerals,
in the exploitation
and in the supply chain.
And also in the development of a lot
of the new post-carbon energy
generation and infrastructure:
solar cells, wind, batteries,
that kind of thing,
electric automobiles.
And so the Chinese are basically saying,
we're going to look at some of those
critical minerals that we dominate,
and we're going to put licensing
regimes on those.
And if you stick with the problems
you give us on semis,
we're going to start putting
export controls there.
Now, the difference is
the Americans will still be able
to buy all of that stuff.
It will just be more expensive.
So the Chinese can't cut off the Americans
the way the Americans
and the South Koreans
and the Dutch can cut off the Chinese,
but they can make it really painful.
And ultimately, all of this
is about relative power.
All of this is about relative gains.
It's not about like, you know,
destroying, the Americans aren't going
to destroy China and vice versa.
But it does mean that as the world
barrels towards an effort
to transition from primarily
fossil fuel-developed energy
to primarily post-carbon-developed energy
over the period of one generation,
that it will be far less efficient
because of this big fight
between the United States and China.
And at the same time,
we are seeing a number
of governments around the world
put industrial policies in place
to provide subsidies
for their own workforces,
governments that have access
to a lot of these critical minerals
that are saying, we can use this
to get up the supply chain.
So we want to make sure
that you're investing that new technology
in our country and not just exploiting
us for our resources,
all of which is creating significant,
politically induced costs
in that big sector
of the global environment
at a time that you want those costs
to be as low as possible
so you can move away
from fossil fuels, right?
I mean, the more expensive
the critical minerals are,
the bigger the barriers,
the harder it's going to be
to go from coal and oil and gas
to all of this new sustainable stuff.
In 2024, that's becoming
a significant fight.
HW: Everything, everywhere, all at once.
Everything is interconnected, is I think
a theme of this conversation.
I will flag for everybody
that there are 10 risks
that you are flagging this year.
We have not had time
to go through them all,
so I would highly recommend
that you go and read the full report.
I'm going to, spoiler alert,
just flag something that you wrote
right at the end of the report, Ian,
that I think is really beautiful and worth
holding close as we go into 2024:
"... that it is critical we don't just
talk about these global issues
to help make business
and policy decisions,
but also to connect
to those closest to us.
If we can't make a difference with those
we know and love, we are lost."
Ian, you are a poet, it turns out.
IB: I don't know if I'd go that far,
but I'd like to believe I care
about my fellow people.
And this is a tough year.
Look, I mean, I just came back
from the South Pole, of all places.
It's a place that I've
always wanted to visit.
By virtue of my job,
I travel all around the world.
And this is this massive continent
at the bottom of the planet
that I've never been to.
And it just looks like this
big thing of ice.
But this also felt like a year
that being off the grid
and connected to the planet,
but not like in the headlines,
in the news, every moment.
It was very useful just in terms
of clearing my head a bit.
But also, as a political scientist,
being in a place that for 60-some years
now we've managed to govern,
if I can use that term loosely,
in a way that protects it
for future generations
and for the planet.
And there used to be all of these
competing territorial claims
by all these different countries.
And now we actually have a treaty
that says we're not going to have
any resource exploitation.
We're not going to use this
for military bases,
we're just going to use it for science,
and we're just going
to keep it for the planet.
We're melting it, I know,
because of global challenges.
But the reality is it still kind of is
the way that we wanted it to be,
was the first arms control agreement
that was ever signed
between the Americans
and the Soviets back in 1959,
and the treaty holds true until 2048.
And when I talked about it,
when I just came back,
I had some people that were saying,
oh, well, you know, 2048,
the Chinese are going to be like,
looking on how they can exploit it,
and the Russians, it's not going to last.
It's like, you know, if we've
got something that works
and is going to work until 2048
in today's environment,
like, that's a win, right?
I mean, we don't know where we're going
to be in three months right now.
And it turns out that we as human beings
are capable, sometimes,
when we put our minds to it
of being stewards.
And we need to do more of that.
The thing that worries me
the most about 2024
is we have a lot of very big,
very real fights happening right now,
and no one's acting like a leader.
No one's acting like a steward.
People are all focused
on a very narrow view
of what's at stake for them
and the people that like them.
And that's not humanity, right?
It's very ephemeral.
And and when we all leave this planet,
after this very short spell
that we have here,
we all go back to the same place
where all the same atoms.
And we need to take a little bit of time
to connect with the people around us,
to remember that.
That's what I took away most
from my little trip
down to the bottom of the planet.
And I'd like to try to hold
that with me as we get through 2024.
HW: May we all borrow that,
may we all have that sensibility in mind
as we go through this year.
Ian, thank you so much for your time.
IB: Thank you, Helen.